[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds of challengers no
winners we have never made a mistake I
know we don't never not including all of
this yeah
maybe tonight not so much anyway this
evening of fan in Germany with the
screen a screen name lemons lemons
mutilating Buddha lemons muta 15 Thank
You hare Richter hmm
Levens beautif if keen says he thinks he
caught a mistake on the show he says it
happened recently when we had a certain
guest on the program hey Colin on
Thursday night's show you continued what
we got Javier Bardem name wrong
uh you pronounced his first name as
hobby' on as if it rhymed with caveat
Javier Bardem
but even when hobby o pronounce his own
name correctly in the interview you
still didn't pick up on it today is the
Kabir bartending day in Hollywood you're
not the only one with dreams you know
Javier frankly I always thought from
your days as commando that your Spanish
pronunciation wasn't all that bad anyway
I'm anxious to see how you get out of
this one say in your chunk meat well I'm
anxious to find out why you live in a
Barnes & Noble
[Music]
any whose labels view the 15 that's even
your real name which obvious is not I'm
sorry to tell you you're dead wrong his
name is pronounced haviar and it does
rhyme with caviar how do I know
because before every single interview I
do I always call the guest mother to
make sure I'm pronouncing the name
correctly for Javier Bardem I called his
mother in Spain Maria that'll pill out
about them munos you don't believe me
let's talk to her right now
[Music]
connection seems to be working well as
dias Senora Bardem witness the earth
Makonnen Ito's bien yo se que usted yeah
mellow Hideko parody me otra vez por
favor como from Sierra nombre de su hijo
sister Lucia Xavier no Xavier Xavier ksl
or attend a lesson hombre I'll embrace
una comida de on de dos cosas smoo
especiales el primero s mckerrod oto
Javier in Barcelona in Santo El Segundo
es la comida favorito de Matteo Xavier
caviar no no caviar ensalada de bar I
mean you have a Lincoln table
Cincinnatus d'Ivoire and salar de ba si
gracias Senor about them you know tell
respeto como nombre service creo que es
una do Tom
[Applause]
I didn't get that last part but she
seems nice
[Laughter]
and she still in character yeah
challenge still then she got quite a
mustache the challenge still stands if
you think you've bought in an era on our
show reported at team koco.com /a - than
ever we will sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chuck meat out of the
maestro